[Musica]
la prima domanda che l'istituto europeo
di tecnologie mi ha fatto è perché
dobbiamo agire oggi
contro la scarsità idrica e io ho
risposto dobbiamo agire oggi per non
reagire domani perché oggi stiamo
facendo questo stiamo reagendo
a quello che abbiamo fatto in passato
sono poi arrivato qui
e parliamo di countdown
il tema lo stesso conto alla rovescia
solo ingegnere ambientale quando ho
iniziato a studiare questa materia ma
c'è una queste fu turo e 30 anni che mi
sento dire questo il futuro
e allora oggi vedo greta sono
felicissimo di vederla
mi hanno chiesto di essere semplice ma
io oggi vi voglio inondare di conoscenza
perché sono stufo di vedere chi si
informa dal telefonino dal tweet nole
dobbiamo leggere dobbiamo studiare
dobbiamo aumentare la nostra conoscenza
il countdown non ho iniziato concreta
nel 1962
questa signora e sono contento una donna
le donne hanno un ruolo centrale ha
scritto questo libro la primavera
silenziosa
questo libro è stato scritto perché
quell estate i grilli non hanno cantato
ed è stato l'avvio
della consapevolezza ambientale
della consapevolezza su le problematiche
dell'inquinamento
nel 1968 a roma in italia
il club di roma ha scritto il libro i
limiti del pianeta
greta non era neanche nei pensieri dei
suoi genitori
il countdown è iniziato 50 anni fa ce ne
stiamo rendendo conto adesso è lì è
iniziato a parlare di sostenibilità
successivamente abbiamo
voluto questa questo concetto
e siamo passati da
un principio di antropocentrismo a un
principio di egocentrismo
dove l'uomo è parte del tutto
e la donna è parte del tutto perché
leggo centrismo lumley la donna era
risolto perché questo è il pensiero di
50 anni fa e oggi pensiamo allo sviluppo
sostenibile in ottica aziendale in
ottica di pianeta in ottica di
sostenibilità
economica sociale e ambientale perché
sviluppo sostenibile non significa non
avere economia
e siamo passati al concetto delle cinque
pil che vedono la sostenibilità non solo
come recuperare riciclare io mi occupo
di acque di rifiuti ma il riciclo è una
parte della sostenibilità perché la
prima parte della stabilità delle
persone che persone per non lasciare
nessuno indietro
da qui abbiamo generato l'agenda 20 30 e
quando i miei studenti al quinto
nell'ingegneria chiedo conoscete gli
obiettivi supposte nibile beh si alzano
il 10 per cento delle mani e sono gli
ingegneri ambientale
ci dobbiamo fare delle domande
l'informazione del tweet forse è troppo
rapida dobbiamo studiare dobbiamo
conoscere per partecipare altrimenti non
riusciamo a partecipare
[Applauso]
e lo scorso anno ci siamo svegliati con
questa pandemia
abbiamo rivisto gli animali nelle città
ogni anno sembra livella di totò
in agosto c'è agosto luglio lo per jules
dei quando noi finiamo le risorse
sostenibili del pianeta per lo scorso
anno vedete siamo qui
abbiamo recuperato un mese ma quest'anno
e siamo tornati a livelli pre pandemia
forse non abbiamo imparato abbastanza
non abbiamo parlato abbastanza e se
continuiamo a vivere come stiamo vivendo
pretendendo che paesi in via di sviluppo
debbano rallentare la loro crescita
perché noi vogliamo continuare a vivere
come stiamo facendo noi conosciamo molte
più risorse
col nostro tenore di vita di quanto
fanno i paesi in via di sviluppo vedete
quanto è complesso arrivare alla
sostenibilità
non ci dobbiamo stupire di quanto
dobbiamo usare il rigore scientifico
perché licenziati dicono questo stiamo
stagione del pianeta e quando ci
chiedono di riff rasare di fare green
washing la risposta deve essere chiara
io ho i numeri se tu hai dei numeri
parliamone bla bla bla noi non abbiamo
il fatto
lo facciamo con la scienza
cosa vuol dire acqua beh quando parliamo
di acqua puntualmente ci viene proposta
all'immagine del deserto ci vengono
proposte le persone che non bevono per
oggi problema dell'acqua e soprattutto
di sanitation è la gestione dei nostri
reflui perché
due miliardi di persone non hanno
accesso all'acqua potabile ma 4.5
miliardi non hanno accesso servizi
igienici pensate questo cosa comporta in
termini di sostenibilità e salute cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che l'approccio
all'acqua deve essere più complessivo
l'immagine del rubinetto è limitante
perché non è solo quello e l'immagine
del deserto del sahara quando parliamo
di acqua e assolutamente
deviante perché deviante per forse ce ne
siamo accorti 2017 quando per la prima
volta nella storia roma si è trovata a
corto di acqua e la prima volta nella
storia
in quell'estate sette regioni italiane
su 20 sono state accorto di acqua siamo
una regione mediterranea c'erano state
problematiche locali ma ci siamo
svegliati capendo che attenzione
dobbiamo fare qualcosa
tant'è vero che
l'italia è il cinquantesimo paese del
mondo circa per scarsità idrica e
dobbiamo
pensare che la domanda di acqua sta
aumentando quindi dire che l'acqua è
acqua potabile vuol dire non avere
l'approccio più
complesso che oggi ha chiesto dal nuovo
green deal che ho già chiesto dall
ambiente che ti circonda
semplificare molto spesso non funziona
semplificare vuol dire molto spesso non
aver studiato prima di parlare prima
studia poi parla quando mi fanno domande
anche giornalisti e mi chiedono ci può
dire qualcosa su quello del professore è
piuttosto noto ma no io prima devo
studiare sono argomento che non conosco
aspetti è ma la notizia e oggi purtroppo
non posso aiutarti parlare dopo aver
studiato e studiare complesso perché
quando si parla di acqua
oggi abbiamo parlato di acqua e cibo ma
per trasportare l'acqua serve energia
tanti mi dicono abbia finita l'acqua
perché c'è la prendo dal mare è la di
salo si e poi come una pompa appennino
quanta energia ci serve per produrre
acqua e e quando da pompi quando diritti
energia quanti gas climalteranti e metti
quanto incide sui cambiamenti climatici
e poi e poi quando vai incidere sulla
biodiversità
ricordate che quando avremo perso
biodiversità il pianeta sarà finito è
quello il limite da non raggiungere
quindi è un aspetto che deve aprire la
nostra mente so bene che non è facile ma
è tutto
fattibile quando ci pensiamo un attimo
chiudiamo gli occhi e pensiamo all'aria
vediamo che c'è dell'acqua nell'aria
pensiamo al valore dell'acqua e perché
no a marzo ti do marzo della giornata
maria dell'acqua andiamo a vedere il
report e qual è l'argomento che riguarda
l'acqua e vedremo che l'argomento che
riguarda l'acqua è il 2019 non lasciare
nessuno indietro quanto è importante per
la società l'acqua è stato acqua e
cambiamenti climatici è stata acqua e
soluzioni naturali è stato acque reflue
ed è stato il valore dell'acqua che vuol
dire che l'acqua è trasversale e quindi
deve essere considerata come tale
e noi scienziati dei ricercatori che
lavoriamo molto in europa e nel mondo
come approcciamo questo problema beh il
concetto è quello dell'acqua multipla
cosa vuol dire acqua multipla ha come
ultima vuol dire vedere non solo la
quantità ma la qualità dell'acqua
utilizzare la qualità che mi serve dalla
fonte che mi serve
industria agricoltura nelle nostre case
hanno bisogno di una diversa qualità
dell'acqua quando vede un'acqua limpida
probabilmente molto più inquinata di un
acqua torbida dove basterebbe separare
la parte solida per avere un'acqua molto
più pulita
quindi andare a utilizzare fonti d'acqua
per opportuno utilizzo è quanto ci
permette di
creare un sistema circolare che oggi può
essere molto
facilitato dalla digitalizzazione
della legislazione che può beneficiare
dell'intelligenza artificiale the
machine learning perché oggi abbiamo i
dati per poter dare sicurezza questo
utilizzo dell'acqua e quindi andare
anche a creare nuova economia l'economia
digitale che vuol dire sostenibilità e
quindi creare nuovi mercati
perché essere
esperto di ambiente vuol dire anche
pensare allo sviluppo economico
sostenibile senza trascurare
l'importanza della resilienza e quindi
delle soluzioni naturali
questa e l'innovazione del settore
medico queste sono
la visione
la ricerca europea
è in questo contesto
chi si occupa di acqua beh questo è
bellissimo
acqua ed economia circolare questo è
della l macarthur foundation e non
troviamo tenere dell'acqua soltanto
troviamo google troviamo aziende del
settore food troviamo aziende che si
occupano di dati da qui capiamo quanto
il settore idrico può veramente essere
un propulsore di sostenibilità e di
economia
tutto questo però lo voglio declinare
anche in una complessità del nesso di
cui parlavo prima da qui a vedere come
tutti siamo coinvolti e andiamo a vedere
a quegli esempi pratici
mi sono occupato di coordinare grossi
azioni di innovazione europee dove in
realtà dice ma tu fai ricercano siamo 30
partner 20 sulle aziende quindi i
ricercatori supportano le aziende che a
fine progetto sono indipendenti e
sviluppano la loro il loro business
circolare tutti questi progetti che
vedete anno per più di 70 per cento
aziende europee e internazionali c'è una
forte collaborazione europea forse sono
ricerca scientifica il primo settore in
cui l'europa è stata centrale per
sviluppare questa conoscenza e vi
parlerò di economia circolare di
digitalizzazione e di soluzioni naturali
parliamo dell'economia circolare beh
quando chiedo
ma l'acqua doveva finire boh c'è un
qualche posto di che puzza
ma la bolletta e la meletta è si vero
che la deputazione posto un sacco di
soldi costa più di quanto mi portano
l'acqua a casa
e vero la depurazione
comporta un consumare energia per pulire
quell'acqua che prima avevo sporcato per
fare i miei utilizzi ma
i nostri depuratori possono diventare
fabbriche di risorse e questo è quanto
abbiamo fatto ad esempio con l'azione di
innovazione smartplant che ha preso
depuratori esistenti
è da questi depuratori ha creato nuova
materia quale materia recuperata ha
creato beh ha creato biopolimeri ha
creato nuove cellulosa ha creato il mio
compositi energia biocarburanti e
biofertilizzanti
in che modo la create le ha create
andando però a stare molto attenti a
quanto questo era fattibile non solo in
termini economici perché giustamente le
aziende ci credono ma sta cosa sta in
piedi la classica frase sta in piedi
si sta in piedi noi lo dicevamo anche in
termini di impronta di carbonio quanti
gas climalteranti e metto e ovviamente
in termini di riutilizzi beh dai
depuratori noi abbiamo alla fine
prodotto materiali isolanti
bio plastiche bio compositi
biocarburanti sapete depuratore attuali
cosa producono tra l'acqua producono il
classico fallo di depurazione che un
rifiuto dove l'abbiamo fatto non
l'abbiamo fatto nei nostri laboratori
l'abbiamo fatto in sé depuratore in
europa
depuratori che vanno oltre due milioni
di abitanti depuratori piccoli abbiamo
creato questo clima collaborativo
dimostrando come ogni persona ogni anno
sapete quanta da digerire utilizziamo
noi dai 10 ai 15 chili all'anno in
europa e in altri paesi più o meno ne
possiamo recuperare 78 kg così come
possiamo recuperare un chilo di
biopolimeri prima degradabili possiamo
fare compositi e fare biocompositi e
creare un nuovo mercato per la tele
dell'acqua che oggi possono vedere un
nuovo sviluppo circolare ma insieme a
questo
ridurre l'impronta ambientale ridurre le
emissioni di gas climalteranti è
come pensare all'accettazione dei
cittadini stelline sono pronti a questo
bene noi abbiamo chiesto
in varie indagini cosa ne pensate a
guardare una roba pulsano la tocco
questo è un tavolo in cui il 50 per
cento e carta igienica recuperata non
quindi utilizzata scaricata e recuperata
avere un colore marrone una volta quali
abbiamo chiesto a queste persone
sapete dove state mangiando sì questo
era una volta della foglia hanno
continuato a mangiare beatamente quindi
far domande non basta bisogna
sperimentare bisogna dare chiari esempi
per arrivare poi a sviluppare quello che
era nei laboratori e questo l'impianto
che sarà in veneto e porta in piena
scala quello che noi abbiamo fatto e per
arrivare a pianificare le città per
avere ero a pianificare le città in modo
circolare perché le nostre città andrà
ad ospitare 70 per cento della
popolazione
siamo tanto pensando andare delle aree
interne ma la realtà è che nel mondo le
70 piacente popolazioni di fran delle
città affinché non pensiamo a come
integrare questi flussi di rifiuti
nel flussi di materia della città e
questo è l'esempio di amsterdam
probabilmente non riusciremo mai a
diminuire la nostra impronta ambientale
e in una città circolare vede questa è
la mappa di amsterdam e vedete come i
depuratori forniscono cellulosa
forniscono biopolimeri alle industrie
che vanno a fare materiali da
costruzione
la pianificazione della città parte
ancora una volta dalla conoscenza e non
mi sembra che questo sia
bla bla bla ma
come rendere quantitativo tutto questo
con i dati con la digitalizzazione
oggi abbiamo un enormità di dati a
disposizione
da questi dati possiamo osservare la
disponibilità di acqua del pianeta è
quello che ad esempio abbiamo fatto nel
bacino del lago di garda
dobbiamo digitalizzare anche il pointer
che
a volte sembra più complesso
beh abbiamo messo a punto dei droni
acquatici che riescono a monitorare la
qualità dell'acqua in che modo in modo
da vedere non solo qual è l'effetto
degli scarichi diffusi delle delle
scariche puntuali a vedere anche qual è
l'effetto degli scarichi diffusi perché
quando la qualità dell'acqua diventa non
tale da poterlo utilizzare molto spesso
è quanto noi tutti facciamo non solo
quanto le industrie o i depuratori fan è
con sistemi robotici con sistemi di
grandi dati riusciamo a far sì che anche
i cittadini questi sistemi sono operati
dei ragazzi
utilizzassero questi sistemi per
conoscere altrimenti io vedo un fiume e
puntualmente solo quando lo vedo torbido
mi preoccupo probabilmente una delle
torbide perfettamente pulito
stiamo lavorando ancora sul digitale qui
siamo a milano e vedete stiamo lavorando
dalla fognatura fino al campo per
riutilizzare l'acqua utilizzando sistemi
robotici sistemi di dati che vanno a
creare un sistema che purtroppo che
piuttosto che utilizzare acqua di fiumi
acqua di falda
riutilizza le acque trattate in maniera
da controllare la sicurezza e quando
abbiamo chiesto come la berretta e la
vostra acqua trattata la gente diceva
non lo so allora siamo inventati questo
un gioco serio
cos'è il gioco serio il gioco serio è
un gioco che fa sì che lo studente
diventi agricoltore
andando a scegliere che cosa coltivare
sulla base dell'impronta ambientale
della propria città
quindi gioco serio per stimolare lo
studio per stimolare la conoscenza e qui
vi lascio anche qualche cure code che
può servire per andare a giocare e anche
darci vostro feedback su quello che
stiamo facendo
infine con
il riutilizzo stiamo lavorando anche sui
legge industriale pensate siamo in
toscana in toscana c'è il sito industria
risolve che utilizza acqua da oltre 100
anni
beh solvay ha deciso di riutilizzare
l'acqua dai depuratori per liberare
acqua di falda che può essere utilizzata
e fare acqua potabile 4 milioni circa di
metri cubi nelle utilizzati dai
depuratori questo è uno scopo a livello
regionale che è stato iniziato in italia
per prima in europa da oltre 15 anni e
quando siamo in nella rurale cosa
possiamo fare bene questo lo stiamo
facendo
nelle isole greche di lesvos ditino se
di mykonos tutti con la scala mykonos
per il turismo
noi andiamo a mykonos e non andiamo al
mare
andiamo due autori purtroppo
a ognuno quel che piace fare
arriviamo lì è cosa facciamo
abbiamo costruito qualcosa che possa
sopportare
l'ecoturismo
perché sapete che i turisti vanno matti
per l'ananas ma amico non sono sito duce
ananas perché manca l'acqua
beh dobbiamo trovare il modo di trattare
l'acqua di recuperare l'acqua piovana
per avaria andare a fare agroecologia in
modo da supportare l'economia locale che
fatto soprattutto di turismo
questo è quindi il mio messaggio con
esempi pratici cosa fa la ricerca
scientifica
cosa fa l'innovazione perché questo
perché oggi sono qui a basso e domani
beh domani per tutti noi sarà come oggi
oggi come ieri non abbiamo iniziato con
greta countdown quando ha iniziato
almeno il 60 due ma forse prima e
dobbiamo agire per non reagire perché
perché dobbiamo sperare che la primavera
non c'è più silente come quella che è
stata una 62 ma che tornerà a essere una
espressione d'arte come diceva
botticelli che è nell'ultima slide si
arriva grazie mille
[Applauso]